hey friends so 2 weeks ago I made a Q&A
announcement to coincide with reaching
100,000 subscribers and Y all well you
definitely delivered with some amazing
questions which I am now here to answer
if I could be any animal what animal
would I be and what are my thoughts on
the future of the pois spinning and
flowarts Community the answers to these
questions and more coming up in this
video
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I am diving into your
questions in honor of making it to
100,000 subscribers here on YouTube but
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark bunk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyrot teror light toys spinballs
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-b buus friend of the
channel Becca becklen thank you so much
for supporting my channel my work and my
mission so first up yes it's time to
flex check this bad boy out my silver
play button um this is kind of a fun
thing to have it's kind of both heavier
and lighter than I was expecting um
these are apparently all handmade and so
there are some interesting little
artifacts along the edge where it's been
carved out but probably the thing that I
think is coolest about it is the button
itself is polished down to being a
mirror so you can see a reflection of
yourself every time you look at it
because uh in case you didn't have a big
enough ego from reaching 100,000
subscribers just you know make sure you
can see yourself every time you look at
your plaque too I got asked a lot of
questions so many in fact that this
video would have been more than an hour
long if I had answered each and every
one so I did my best to select those
that I thought would have the most
interesting answers and also two to
select uh individual questions that have
been asked by multiple people and
prioritize them in the queue and if I
don't answer your question in this video
I will do my best to go back and answer
your original comment so let's go ahead
and dive in MIP Ty thas asks any plan
for a new chair what's wrong with my
chair PewDiePie 10 whistle asks what's
one thing that gets said all the time
about pois spinning that you find a
little bit annoying in all honesty if I
hear one more person making a joke about
us playing with our balls I am going to
roll my eyes yet again but yeah that
that that's the one that always drives
me a little nuts Jessica lipo 9117 asks
are you still learning tricks or are you
at the point where you know all the
tricks or learn new ones instantly I do
not know all the tricks I will never
know all the tricks no human being
possibly can and that's okay because
we're still always in the process of
discovering new ones what I got over the
years was just kind of an acceptance
that that's the way of things and
looking at it less in terms of having to
learn all of the things and More in
terms of thinking well what are the
things to learn that are going to be a
good compliment to my style and are
going to uphold my Approach to flow
lovery atper asks if you could be any
animal which one would you be so you
didn't specify extinct or living here
and I'm not exactly sure how I should
read that into the premise of the
question because there are some extinct
animals that I think are just
fascinating uh if we're talking extinct
animals I would love to be my favorite
one uh danicus a dros sorid uh Manor
raptoran from the early Cretaceous of
Montana if we're talking about a living
animal I think I'd be split between
being a gorilla just because I think
they're really cool and being a wolf
which uh has come up multiple times in
my life that my my inner nature is very
wolflike so take from that what you will
so Justin weismer media 8603 asked me a
bunch of questions I've selected just a
few here but I'm going to go through
them one by one where are you based
these days around the Northeast Us near
DC yes I am in Tacoma Park Maryland it
is a suburb of Washington DC that is uh
just on the outside of the Northeast
edge of the Washington DC Diamond what
are the top five best or most common po
moves for a beginner to learn I made a
video on that topic a couple of them in
fact but I do believe that my thinking
has changed somewhat on that topic since
I made those videos so off the top of my
head I think that the py tricks that
people should start with are things like
extensions and extends that is the type
of pendulums where you go around in big
circles with your arms in addition uh I
would put butterflies on that list I
would also put pendulums as a transition
tool on that list simply because I don't
think that there's a style of poy that
doesn't benefit from starting with uh
pendulums as your primary transition
tool from the start you can learn stalls
a little bit later for the final trick
of those beginner five I would say that
I would make it reals and
specifically uh reals and Performing
Reals in such a way that you learn how
to do sha steps with them so you can
explore the space around you a little
bit which one of your beginner series is
the best for a new pois spinner to learn
is it your Co series are you planning to
do another beginner Series in the near
future funny you should ask this
question if we're talking purely about
lessons that are available without a pay
wall then yes my covid series is the
best one that I currently have out there
uh if we expand our search to resources
that are behind a pay wall I would
actually say go back and check out the
live stream lessons that I started on
crowdcast I want to say like a year and
a half maybe two years ago um that was
my second attempt to go through the
material from the covid series which was
material that I had been working on for
years as a new beginner series and I'm
pretty happy with how it went in the
live stream lessons you can go back and
watch recorded versions of them by the
way I'll I'll link to that down below um
but I'm at a point where I I think I
feel safe creating a new beginner series
around that material so hopefully that's
coming before the end of the year I
think I can I think I can how does
traditional LED POI compare to fire POI
is it mostly the same or are there any
significant variations in what should be
switched in the style I would say that
there are very significant differences
Chief among them is the fact that with
most LED poy if you're in the dark you
cannot see the performer uh with fire
POI even if you're in the dark you can
see the performer so with LED po you
tend to work more with tricks that
create uh great patterns in their Trails
truth be told uh if you want to see some
of the best LED po spinning in action
look to Glow stringers because that is
really the art that they've cultivated
over the years they create a lot of
spirals they keep everything in wall
plane in front of them you add some
flowers on top of that and you're good
to go with fire po ironically enough you
have kind of the opposite requirements
in that you kind of want to avoid having
them come come a little bit too close to
your body so unless you have protection
wraps are out um but with fire POI doing
more 3D stuff becomes tenable once again
so things like body tracers and uh plane
brakes and things like that really do
show up well with
uh this is actually a great topic for a
video in general if y'all would like to
get my recommendations on stylistically
how to write routines that work best for
each medium leave me a comment and let
me know what's your preference for music
when spinning poi uh it changes by the
week if not sometimes the day but by and
large I like rock music I like pop music
I like some hip-hop uh the only genre I
really kind of steer away from is Eed M
so like uh the past few weeks I've been
practicing a lot listening to top 40
music and I've actually been finding
that a lot of what's in the top 40
charts right now is a great fit for a
lot of my PO Dance warm-ups um if you're
asking about what earworm is in my head
right now and that I am listening to
nearly constantly when I just need
something to fill the space that song
would be Blame It On Your Love by
Charlie XCX featuring lizo
cannot get enough of that one how do you
come up with new routines and
choreographies this is a great question
and the answer really depends upon the
specific piece of choreography that I'm
putting together um sometimes I will see
a combination of moves in my head and be
curious hey can I actually do that in
real life and I'll work through it and
sometimes I'll find that I can't but
there's something else that's similar
that I still like a lot of the time
though it starts with the music like
I'll be on Instagram seeing what music
is trending or something will pop up in
my uh Apple music suggested feed and as
I'm listening to that song I will just
see movement in my head I really look
for the musicality in putting together
choreography so you know if a song has
got a particular beat I start seeing
footwork in my head that goes with that
beat if there's a really cool Melody
line I'll see different poy tricks that
go with that generally speaking I start
with what I see in my head and see how
closely I can do that in reality and in
a lot of cases I'll also find that as
I'm working through a piece of music
I'll just see what feels natural in my
body to do at different
points the big uh the big kind of
editing process on this though is to
shoot video of it and see how much what
feels right matches up with the feel of
the music how do you handle injuries or
setbacks in your POI practice I mean I'm
in my 40s now so it takes a long time to
recover from injuries um they've been
happening less frequently though and I
think that that's because I started
getting into the habit of stretching
every other day so because that's a part
of my regular routine now I actually
don't remember the last time uh I got
injured so I would recommend that to
everybody out there regardless of age
what equipment do you use for filming
your videos and do you have any tips for
creating quality POI content all right
so first and foremost equipment um I am
shooting this on a Sony
a6500 uh I got a Carl ice lens on there
I believe it's a 24 mm goes to
f1.8 uh I've got two aperture LED panels
one that is giving me this rembrand
lighting and the other one that is
mounted back behind that room divider to
give me the negative space around my
head love it love all the lighting as
for the question of tips for creating
quality content
so um here's my biggest piece of advice
here the equipment that you're using by
and large does not matter what matters
is the quality of the content the story
that you're telling the information that
you're getting across and how you get
across it I'm am actually a firm
believer in telling people to start with
terrible equipment and figuring out how
to become a good content creator as a
result of it before they upgrade to
better equipment why because by the time
they've made that investment they are
already good enough to create creating
content that they're going to see a
massive change in engagement as a result
of it if you go for the equipment first
you're going to spend a whole bunch of
money on stuff that you're not going to
know how to use and the quality of the
content that comes out of it is not
going to be very good the biggest
question anybody should ask before they
even start to shoot a single second or
write a single sentence of any content
is why does this content need to exist
what does my audience get out of this
piece of content is this something to
inspire them is this something that
they're going to learn from Does this
answer a question that they have um if
you cannot answer that question then
don't create the content straight up
because if you are not serving your
audience then they're not going to
interact with your content at all what
are your long-term goals for your PO
practice and YouTube
channel asking the big questions here so
I will give you some specifics and I
will give you some generalities some
specifics
I would really like to be doing more
work with po dance um specifically I
would like to have in-person classes
again I would like to be doing Workshop
tours again because I think that's how I
want to interact with people out in the
world uh in face to face um longer term
I would really love to put together a
stage show of my PO dance work at this
point there's a big enough volume of it
that I think that that would be a fun
challenge and also I I have some things
to pull from on
that more generally what all of that
says to me is that I want bigger
challenges to throw my artistic muscles
at and specifically I really want to
show the potential of what po dance can
offer the world in terms of being an
expressive art instead of kind of being
the uh the action sport or skill toy
that we've traditionally looked at it as
can you recommend any books tutorials or
resources for po Spinners yes I can
although whether they can get access to
them is another question entirely uh so
the book I would recommend to PO
Spinners would be the Rhythm and life of
Po by uh ngam wat I I'm dead sure I'm
not pronouncing that right but I'm
trying um it is a book by a Maui po
Elder uh about not just how Maui POI is
performed and built and spun but also
about kind of the history of Maui Legend
and culture that goes into POI
performance that failing there's a
wonderful paper by uh Karen
parang that is a history of Po going
back to the settling of the Polynesian
Islands um I think even before the
settling of Al aroa New Zealand um that
traces the origins of poi from um a
juggling game to the modern part of
kapahaka that that we know it as and how
it has been influenced by colonization
uh and tourism and also too just by
changes in Polynesian and Mau culture
over the centuries it's a fantastic read
right now that is kind of my Bible for
how I think about the history of Po
before it became the social media
phenomenon that it is now uh I'll link
to it down in the description highly
recommended Sky Guys Quest asks can you
please bring back the double staff
content um so short answer is maybe um
so YouTube has changed a lot since I was
making double staff content and one of
the ways it has changed is that it is
very very risk averse in terms of how
the algorithm works so believe it or not
if I were to bring back double staff
content the smartest way for me to do
that would actually be to start up a
second Channel centered around just
double staff content and leave this one
focused on PO I already have a lot of
work on my plate I'm not sure I want to
do that but maybe if there's enough
demand who knows rosile asks I'm not
sure if you've heard of Rose Thorn bud
but I'd love to hear yours for your own
flow as well as the flow community in
general what is one thing you are happy
with one thing you are struggling with
and one thing you were excited for I
love this exercise this is fun so with
my own flow one thing that I am happy
with is the musicality that I'm seeing
coming out of my PO dance just in
general as a content creator I struggle
with the fact that I have to wear so
many hats at the same time like I'll
spend an entire day shooting video and
I'm glad that I got it done but then
I'll come out of it so exhausted and
I've got to go back and edit all of it
and I wish I had somebody whose job it
was to do that editing but the problem
is I just don't make enough money doing
this to be able to pay somebody else to
do it so I I have to wear too many hats
right now and I wish that I didn't one
thing that I'm excited for is that I
started work on a new po dance piece to
a full length song rather than just
doing a 30 second snippet for Instagram
I'm actually going to choreograph the
full song and I'm enjoying how that's
going thus far and I can't wait to see
what the results eventually are and as
for the flow Community I think one thing
that I'm happy with in the flow
Community is that we more or less
survive the pandemic we Sur survived a
period in which everybody was kind of
locked down and unable to interact with
people in a meaningful way in person and
that made it very difficult for a lot of
elements traditionally part of the flow
Arts to be able to continue and Thrive
there are many things I think we're
struggling with in the flow Arts
Community some of which are going to
come up in a later question in this Q&A
um but I think one of the biggest is
just trying to figure out what our
identity is right now because I think
that we've had a couple different
competing ideas for what that is
partially as a result of the pandemic
and partially as a result of some forces
economic and cultural that were uh
having an impact on us even before that
I think the thing that I'm most excited
for in the flow Community is just the
increasing number of people that I'm
seeing in it that embrac dance as an
aspect of their flow it used to be that
it was like Ty roachford and zova and me
and that was basically it but just in
the past few months alone I can think of
at least a dozen new po dancers that I
have seen out there including some that
have come about as a result of taking my
classes or tuning into my videos and
that makes me feel really good and
really excited for what comes next
Justin Blanchard 1470 asks love the
return to traditional po videos any
thoughts on embarking further down that
rabbit hole and or traveling to New
Zealand I would love to travel to New
Zealand I would love love love love love
to travel New Zealand
challenges um I don't make a whole lot
of money so a trip to New Zealand is
probably out of my reach uh for the
immediate and maybe middle future as
well that's probably a thing that I
could fundraise for but I I I feel
guilty asking people to give me money to
essentially go on what's a
vacation but who knows maybe maybe I'm
being uh too self-conscious about it so
y'all can let me know down in the
comments comments uh would would you
give to a GoFundMe to send Drex to New
Zealand and come back with loads of
content uh around uh M po spinning or M
POI what am I talking about let me know
down in the comments staff 936 asks how
did you go on the journey from
discovering po to continue to push to
the highest levels of Po I know my own
journey is filled with bright lights
followed by Pitch Black in terms of
where to go next so curious what yours
was like and what are your Briggs
letters so for those who don't know I
first saw firep at Burning Man 2006
which was also my first Burning Man uh
and was specifically saying po Spinners
in conclave that inspired me to want to
pick it up myself so when I got back
from burning man I spent months asking
around to my friends being like hey
what's that fire thing that we saw out
at Burning Man and do we know anybody
who can teach me how to do that so they
said yeah uh our friend Paul uh knows
how to spin Poise so looked up my friend
Paul and I asked him if he teach me I
went and had my first lesson with him
and I was an absolute failure at it and
so I actually gave up um I decided that
PO was not for me and I went on my Merry
way and that would have been the end of
the story were it not for my roommate
who came back from a holiday in Thailand
with a set of fire po that he bought at
a Street Market there for me and he
presented them to me proudly and said
hey you want to learn how to do this
right and um I I felt guilty about
letting him down so I picked them up and
gave it a second can try and I haven't
looked back since but some important
things in particular were number one uh
very early on I read a book called
Mastery by a guy named George Leonard
I'll link to it down in the description
um that essentially suggested to me that
there was a way to master a skill that
involves making the commitment to show
up to keep on working on it every single
day and work through the plateaus learn
to love the plateau he said which was
radically different from how I was
learning any other skill at the time and
and because po was the thing that I had
just picked up I decided okay I'm going
to apply this philosophy to PO and see
how it goes so I made a commitment to
show up and practice it every day and
keep on working on it even on the days
when I didn't feel motivated to do so
and wouldn't you know it the advice
worked as for my Myers Briggs letters um
and yes I have a healthy degree of
skepticism about this as many people do
but the last time I took the test uh I
was an
xnf that is I was right on the dividing
line between introvert and extrovert
intuitive feeling and perceiving so take
from that what you will me
0101001 0000 asks what are your thoughts
on pseudoscientific ideas floating in
and through the flow Community you
mentioned that gatekeeping has been a
pervasive problem in every flow art do
you think that that is still the case
what recommendations do you have for a
buding flow artist wanting to build
their own brand outside of poi what
other things are you passionate about
out okay so a lot of questions let me
tackle the first one because this
actually is something that multiple
people did ask um and this one kind of
came as a surprise to me because I up
until recently never really thought of
the flow Community as being associated
with uh pseudoscientific ideas but I I
see what people are getting at now um I
definitely had a problem in the pandemic
of people getting on my case about uh
being open about the fact that I was
getting vaccinated and regularly using a
mask so when people come into the flow
arts and most specifically when they
come in via the fire arts and elements
of like the transformational festival
community and things like that I think
inherently there is an aspect of that
that is a reaction to modernity and some
anxieties about modernity and wanting to
reconnect to a version of the past or at
least a version of the past that people
believe once existed and because of that
it makes certain segments of the
community more likely to reject elements
of modernity that include things like uh
the scientific method and uh
recommendations uh from uh scientists
because since they're in a place where
they want to trust their own intuition
over all of these things in the modern
world they're already kind of primed to
go there so of course the next and
obvious question is what exactly do we
do about this because there are many
ways in which it definitely hurts theun
community and I don't have a very
satisfying answer to that most of the
resources that I've looked at when it
comes to how exactly we can change
people's minds basically come down to
the fact that you kind of have to give
them space to hold their beliefs and
come to a point where they can question
them by themselves because when people's
beliefs are challenged and even if you
like throw facts at them people will not
change their minds because you're
literally doing a thing to them where
they've developed a community identity
around it and so asking them to change
their mind in many respects is also
asking them to throw away their group of
friends and be alone and isolated and
nobody wants to do this and it's really
difficult it's really time and resource
intensive and unfortunately from what I
can tell from the research there's
there's really not a way around it which
is not to say by the way that we just
need to accept pseudoscientific nonsense
and let that be how things are going to
be but I do think that when we March
into it ready for battle what we wind up
with is Battle and that tends not to be
super helpful in the long term and
believe you me I've got so much more to
say about this topic but I want to keep
this video short so if you'd like to see
a video essay on this topic leave me a
comment and let me know do I think that
gatekeeping is still a problem in the
flow Arts yes and no I think that there
are ways that gatekeeping is applied in
our community that is harmful to the
community and I think that there are
ways that gatekeeping is not applied in
our community that is also harmful to it
so like there is absolutely a lot more
that we can be doing to be welcoming to
new people and also to support people
who come into this community so that
they stay in the community longer and at
the same time I think that there are
some very specific cases where it's okay
for us to say you know you need to put a
certain amount of work into your craft
before you qualify for things like
teaching slots at festivals or
professional gigs I don't think that
it's appropriate for people to just
March in and be able to do that after
they have only spent a few weeks or a
few months learning their craft I think
that those are positions that should be
open to people who've made a choice to
commit themselves to them rather than
things that exist to make people feel
seen as for flow artists wanting to
build their own brand um I would say
number one look at people whose Brands
you admire and try and pick out what is
it about those brands that you find
appealing um number two just get out
there and start making content see what
works see what doesn't um it will teach
you more to try a bunch of things and
find out what doesn't work than you'll
ever be able to by sitting down and
outlining the thing and finally I think
that it helps to spend some time really
thinking about what are the values that
I really want to bring to the world what
are the things that are most important
to me to see out in the world and the
things that I would most like to inspire
in other people see if you can write out
like three to five specific driving
qualities for you and it's a pretty good
bet that those then will be integral
elements of your brand and as for things
outside of Po that I love goodness
that's a long list um I'm trained as a
historian so I still love history I love
paleontology um living in DC is amazing
for that because all the museums here
are incredible um I love puzzles uh I
love comic books uh I love movies I love
TV shows I love music uh I love classic
rock
specifically um there's a lot of things
that I love I love playing music I if I
listed them all off we'd be here all day
economics Behavioral
psychology art history media criticism
okay I'm going to stop there ever tried
to prop and immediately knew it is not
for you and why is it not for you so
this is also going to overlap with
another question a lot of people asked
me which was to share some stories from
my history in the flow arts and this one
in particular has to do with puppy
Hammer because puppy Hammer was invented
by a close friend of mine Charlie
Cushing so there was a point several
years ago at at Wildfire in which uh
Charlie really badly wanted me to take
up puppy hammer and I by the same token
was having a great time with contact poy
and I noticed that you couldn't do
contact poy with puppy Hammer because
the two ends are stuck together so we
agreed that for an hour we would
exchange props I would work with his
puppy hammer and he would work with my
contact poy and we both came back after
that hour and said no this is not for me
there's a lot of puppy Hammer technique
that kind of it isn't just meteor
technique but also almost like contact
staff and contact staff is without a
doubt the least intuitive tool to me it
feels so incredibly difficult and I
cannot wrap my head around it if a
certain trick doesn't work on a day what
do you do drill until it works or stop
and try it a few days later my technique
for learning poy tricks is generally to
break them up into component pieces and
drill those specifically when I do that
I'm doing it from one of two positions
either I'm going for reps of a
particular drill or I set a timer for
them say like 10 20 30 minutes and when
the timer goes off then I'm done doing
that exercise for the day I don't really
subscribe to the idea that if
something's not working that you put it
down you come back to it days later um
if for no other reason then I believe
that is a recipe for learning a thing
that you're never completely in
conscious control of
you have to go through those phases of
learning the trick wherein things are
not working and figuring out how to fix
them
nonetheless rather than coming back and
having all the pieces come together
because if you don't know how the pieces
came together then you won't know how to
fix it when something goes wrong again
what branch of science is your favorite
and why any favorite philosopher I think
I'm going to say paleontology here just
I love dinosaurs I regularly read up on
the latest research that's coming out
around dinosaurs so I think I think
dinosaurs and paleontology would have to
be it as for my favorite
philosopher probably Ralph Waldo Emerson
um I read on the duty of self-reliance
when I was in high school and it really
changed my world in a lot of ways um
there's probably another philosopher
that I'm more philosophically in line
with but Emerson was really the guy that
rocked my world the hardest the earliest
so I'm going to go with him and that was
it friends thankk you for your wonderful
questions and just to put this out there
too um it feels great being at 100,000
subscribers and I just wanted to take a
quick moment to thank everybody who
helped me get to that point all the
people who have tuned in and supported
my channel over the years all of the
companies and people that have been
there that have made it possible for me
to continue working and continue
creating content for the now more than
decade and a half of my career um I
would not be here without you so from
the depths of my heart thank you so very
[Music]
much and speaking of support I have to
throw a shout out out there to my
patreon supporters and in particular uh
I'd love to give a shout out to my Flo
patrons who are listed on screen right
now thank you one and all for supporting
my channel my work and my mission um and
just as like a personal note um those of
you out there that are watching right
now if you're not currently supporter I
would really appreciate it if you would
sign up to become one and here's why
creating content is my passion this is
how I make an impact in the world and
Reach people that I never would be able
to
person and what makes that possible is
the support that I get on patreon and
that support has kind of tapered off a
little in the past year which is
something that a lot of creators have
been encountering in that time and
because of that I've had to shift Focus
over to other things that bring in money
like teaching private lessons and uh
teaching my live stream classes and the
thing is there's only a certain number
of hours in the week so every hour that
I spend teaching private lessons is an
hour that's taken away from producing
content and so the results of that are
things like uh I no longer upload as
much content that has closed captions on
it for example which is something that I
would like to do more of but when push
comes to shove if I've got the choice
between being able to pay rent on time
and doing the Clos captions with an hour
that I have on a Wednesday I have to
choose the thing that brings uh grocery
money in the door so if you would like
to see me be able to go back to
captioning my videos regularly and being
able to spend more time creating
scripted videos so many of you out there
have been saying you've been really
loving the video essays I would love to
make more of those but they take an
enormous amount of time and energy to
produce and I can only do that when I
have things like patreon supporting me
and making it possible to do those
things instead of having to go seek out
work on the side so if you want to see
more of that stuff cuz I know I do um
please go and sign up for my patreon
over at patreon.com drexfactor poo
there's a whole host of amazing rewards
that are available there but really any
amount of support helps um help me keep
this channel alive for the next 100,000
subscribers and hopefully be able to
create better content for them too so go
check that out please and thank you
awesome so I feel really grateful to be
here I feel really grateful for all of
you out there that are watching and I
can't wait to see what the next few
years bring as well so thank you all for
tuning in thank you to everybody who
sent in their questions I will see you
all the new video real soon and uh I'm
excited for the next chapter take care
now peace